[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
un año después del inicio de las
restricciones más estrictas por la
pandemia de kobe 19 el mundo aún no se
recupera la emergencia sanitaria
desencadenó una crisis social y
económica que afecta drásticamente a los
más vulnerables en españa por ejemplo la
situación hizo que muchos inmigrantes
dieran media vuelta de regreso a sus
países de origen más de 90 mil
extranjeros abandonaron españa solo en
los seis primeros meses de 2020 y la
mayoría de los que retornaron fueron
latinoamericanos nuestras corresponsales
conocieron la historia de algunos
inmigrantes afectados por la pandemia en
madrid veamos
vuelta a casa para angélica y brian y
6585 bogotá la pareja colombiana ha
pasado un año en españa pero fue una
decepción
bryant hizo una formación aquí pero no
consiguió encontrar trabajo apenas y si
el curso me quitaron los papeles y me
pusieron un sello de expulsión sin
ningún motivo no explicaron el porqué
nada angélica quería ganar dinero para
su madre enferma intento encontrar
trabajo de cuidadora de personas mayores
pero llegó al peor momento con la
pandemia peor fatal porque si antes por
lo menos hacíamos un aseo de vez en
cuando ahora
y cuando encontró un trabajo la
emplearon sin declarar la mi sol de la
de 600 euros y cuando he terminado mi
trabajo sólo me dieron 180 fue muy duro
porque la señora me ha dicho que si yo
la denunciaba la que perdía era yo ahora
vuelven con sus familias a pereira al
oeste de bogotá tendrán que empezar de
cero
[Música]
la situación es aún más difícil para los
inmigrantes con niños esa asociación les
ayuda después de haber pasado en madrid
un año y medio julie quiere volver a
perú en difícil por la situación que ha
pasado también hoy por la pandemia y lo
que está pasando yo no trabajo con que
pago y tiene que cuidar a su niño que
tiene trastornos de salud mental
entonces nadie la acepto como limpiadora
en comida me ayudaba de cáritas no pero
no era así como que uno yo quiero
trabajar yo quería trabajar bueno
gracias a fondos europeos esa asociación
es comprar billetes a inmigrantes
latinos para financiar el retorno
retorno muchas veces muy doloroso porque
no es un retorno querido y deseado sólo
en esa asociación hay más de 100
familias que esperan poder acceder a un
programa de retorno
en francia las cosas no van mejor para
los inmigrantes en una región al sur de
parís nacionales y extranjeros sin
empleo buscan opciones para llevar
comida a sus familias llevan en meses
desempleados y sobreviven gracias a la
solidaridad de algunas organizaciones
benéficas el alcalde de la localidad de
green y dice que la pandemia desató un
tsunami social que no entiende de
nacionalidades
hasta este banco de alimentos llegan a
menudos rostros conocidos pero de un
tiempo para acá los nuevos visitantes
son más vienen hasta aquí por alimentos
para llevar a casa lo necesitan porque
la pandemia les quito su forma de
sustento danielle es una de las
beneficiadas nació en costa de marfil y
ahora vive indocumentada en francia
vacía de cómo llegué aquí cuando mi hija
tenía tres meses me registre y gracias a
este lugar las cosas van bien en casa
hemos comido un tony wheeler comemos
bien porque nos dan leche y cosas así
dicho caballero antes trabajaba un poco
pero ya no lo hago ya no tengo trabajo
mi pareja y yo estamos en casa una
historia común en esta localidad ubicada
a 30 kilómetros al sur de parís conocida
como la más pobre de francia continental
la frágil situación en la que vivían sus
habitantes que empeoró con la llegada de
la pandemia lo que observamos es que
tenemos gente nueva
caras nuevas y hay gente que no veíamos
antes hay personas que ya no veíamos
pero que volvimos a ver
así que hay gente que empieza a superar
las cosas y boom aquí vamos de nuevo y
es que las cosas estallaron hace un año
cuando el virus obligó a confinamientos
estrictos hola a finales de marzo o
principios de abril vimos este tsunami
este terremoto esta sacudida
extremadamente potente mientras
desplegaba mos toda nuestra energía
posible especialmente para ofrecer el
acceso a los alimentos al norte de las
30.000 personas que aquí reciben casi la
mitad son inmigrantes que viven bajo el
umbral de la pobreza y perciben menos de
900 euros al mes y se teme que la
pandemia haya aumentado esos datos
negativos
el hobbit 19 afecta no sólo a los
trabajadores migrantes que pierden sus
empleos ante la crisis también a sus
familias que esperan remesas en los
países de origen disminuidas
drásticamente por la pandemia y el dato
de migración de la semana
cinco millones quinientos mil refugiados
en la región y seis millones setecientos
mil desplazados internos dejan diez años
de conflicto en siria la mitad de la
población se ha visto obligada a
abandonar su hogar por la guerra durante
la última década
hasta que inmigrantes de france24
seguiremos cubriendo la actualidad de la
migración en américa latina y en el
mundo en todas sus facetas los invitamos
a comentar en nuestras redes sociales
con el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan
conectados con más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]